hey francis do you like books uh only
when they have pictures all the
waterproof ones i can take in the bath
with me all right well for those of you
who can read and enjoy reading satire in
particular we have just the book for you
what's satire shut up the book is called
woke fragility it's a brilliantly funny
takedown of robin d'angelo's white
fragility and woke culture more
generally it will keep you amused
through the small wee hours a
civilization collapses all around you
it's satire as it's meant to be allowing
you to laugh at things the powers that
be have now deemed off limits we all
know that comedy now is more toothless
than joe biden after he's removed his
dentures this is what you need to hit
the funny bone in these demented times
and it's received an average of 4.4
stars on amazon if you've already read
work fragility then tired moderate also
has two other books out the little book
of work jokes and scary stories to tell
the world in the dark a woke parody of
scary stories to tell in the dark i'll
read that book which one the little one
find his books on amazon and enjoy a
satirical book that's funny and playful
you didn't like it no no you didn't like
us i didn't
you know what's hilarious i feel like
i'm doing the rounds speaking to people
that i didn't like and being like i i
love you now
please take me um
and i'll tell you why i didn't um kk
it's because
[Music]
i knew that my story was gonna have to
change
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
frances foster i'm constantine kissen
and this is the show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people i'm absolutely pumped for the
guest we have for you today she's a
writer or speaker and consultant africa
brooke welcome to trigonometry thank you
so much thank you i
ah obviously we've been speaking for a
while before starting to record but i'm
very very excited for this conversation
because i think there are so many
parallels in our stories even though
we're
very different people um and i'm just
really excited that we get to speak
about it here because i admire
everything you both do that's very kind
of you and there was a bit of distancing
as well obviously very different people
keep you over there
very different
very different
yeah yeah we're very different mate just
a quick glance at francis foster there
no africa it's a it's a real pleasure to
have you uh you know there's a bit of a
mutual admiration society going on here
mutual appreciation thing um but before
we get into all of that for people who
don't know you tell everybody who are
you what has been your journey through
life because it has been a fascinating
one it has it has and
some people will be familiar with my
story because i do think our audiences
and our communities cross over a little
bit but i know most people won't be um
but the work that i do today as a writer
as a consultant as a coach as a speaker
it all comes from about five years ago
which is when i got sober
and my journey to sobriety wasn't an
easy one it wasn't me just making a
decision and then just [ __ ] doing it
it was a very
grueling process and when i was 19 years
old i realized that i had a very big
problem with blackout drinking binge
drinking
which i know culturally in this country
specifically is almost seen like a rite
of passage i don't know what it has been
like for you
um but i knew from the very first time
that i drunk that there was something
that wasn't quite
normal if you will because i blacked out
from the very first moment wow and i
blacked out pretty much every other time
after until i got sober at 24
and i had tried seven times to get sober
consciously seven times and you know i
always say that this is not including
the moments where i said i'm never
drinking again or felt some kind of
shame
um seven times trying to get sober and i
relapsed every single time
and in 2016 is when i had just
exhausted myself to the point of
realizing that if i don't get sober now
i'm not going to make it to 25 years old
i'm not going to see another year of my
life
so again it wasn't a profound romantic
decision i didn't do it for myself and
my well-being
um i was losing everyone in my life i
was becoming someone that i didn't even
recognize
the version of me that would come out
when i was blackout drinking is a
version that i wouldn't even be able to
write but i had to apologize for her
actions every single time
and the thing that
kept me and has kept me sober
from 2016 is the curiosity
and even in the work that i do today
curiosity is something i speak about so
much and i'll tell you exactly what i
mean by that
i started to just
wonder what is happening to me on a
brain-based level when i drink in this
way what is keeping me in this
destructive cycle
what is keeping me in a cycle of shame
um feeling like i want to escape my
reality to a point of losing eight hours
because that's the longest that i've
ever blacked out eight hours um and i
remember actually and i'm sure i've
shared this before i remember going to
lunch with a friend we went to lunch in
soho i think it was a monday
and then i woke up a day and a half
later in sorry
[Laughter]
i'll just be very honest about this i
woke up a day and a half later doing
coke at midday in surrey i had no idea
how i had got there
or my friend wasn't there i was with
people that i had never seen before but
this was just one incident of many
but anyway i
started to get curious about what was
happening to me in terms of behavior and
then i just got immersed into a world of
psychology into a world of personal
development
into a world of just hearing different
lecturers speaking different professors
different mentors sharing their stories
i spoke to so many people who were also
addicts that's not a term that i ever
used for myself specifically
but i did realize that i had a big issue
with alcoholism
so
i started to
wonder how i could use my own story not
only to save myself but to maybe connect
with other people that are going through
the same thing
it's when i came across the concept of
self-sabotage which is now a big part of
my work it's my main area of focus why
do we get in our own way
um
and
five years on i mean that's i'm kind of
jumping here but five years on the work
that i do now is heavily influenced by
my sobriety journey and me wanting to
understand human behavior um our
capacity for change that we we can
actually change when we commit to a
different story
and also just understanding the
psychology and science behind all of
that so that's what's led me to what i
do that's one part of it and francis has
a lot of questions and things she wants
to discuss with you about that but also
just to add another part and we talked
about this before we started the show
you know that for us
you know the way we do the show is we
have conversations that we find
interesting
and while i think everybody knows our
particular stance on
wokeness and woke culture and we are not
particularly keen to like just have that
endless conversation over and over
because we're not even sure it's
particularly productive nonetheless one
part of your journey also is that you
wrote an open letter talking about how
you left the workness cult and i'm sure
that had an impact on you as well right
yeah absolutely and the the way that
ties in and i'll get into the lesson but
the way that ties into
the work that i do now self
self-sabotage and understanding
self-censorship
is because
about two years ago it's when i started
to move away from looking at the
individual why does the individual
sabotage why did i censor myself why do
people center themselves
i started to see what was playing out in
our culture and i realized that actually
we might be witnessing a collective
sabotage where it's no longer just the
individual experiencing something and
having to work through it themselves
we have groups of individuals projecting
their own internal happenings onto an
entire society so that's how my work has
shifted into what i do now um so the
letter that i wrote why i'm leaving the
cult of workness was me saying that i'm
not playing that game anymore i'm not
gonna do it i'm not gonna do it because
it started to make me sick in a way that
i can't even explain
it wasn't even just me feeling
emotionally like actually something is
not quite right
but for whatever reason even though i've
always been a very outspoken person
there seems like there are some areas
that other people have decided that i
can't
say anything on or that i have to follow
a very specific script
and this script is based on my identity
markers as a black person as a woman etc
etc
um
and then i just started to realize oh my
goodness i i know all of this well but
the thing is i only know it well in the
sense of sobriety and drinking culture
and why we again get in our own way et
cetera but
i realized that i was starting to see
the same things playing out in our
culture in a different way which is when
i wrote that letter and what moved you
to write the letter was there a
particular epiphany where you go i just
can't do this anymore yeah yeah i would
say 2020 which was
are you surprised
are you surprised
i don't know something a little bit
weird happened in 2020 i don't know what
it was i don't know um it was 2020.
when
and to be even more specific
the racial tensions that were happening
especially in june
um
and the level of dehumanization that i
started to see and here's the thing
when
everything that happened in the u.s
happened with george floyd et cetera
immediately i was on board i was on
board in the sense that something
horrific had just happened and injustice
had taken place
and
as a black person the message that was
essentially presented to me
was one where
just by default i had to also see myself
as victimized
i did there there wasn't any other way
to look at it it wasn't a
something has happened let's sort of
look at it objectively i'm in a
completely different country with a
different history i'm not saying it's a
romantic history at all but it's a very
different history to the us
um
but there wasn't any objectivity there
wasn't any room for critical thinking
you just had to take on the fact
something has happened to a black person
which means that it can happen to you
and you have to take on the exact same
pain and i did
and i was very frustrated and i didn't
even really know why
and i started to see myself
echo even in my own mind echo sentiments
that i would have never
agreed with before for example the idea
that all white people are racist i have
never
in my entire life thought anything like
to me that doesn't make sense and i've
said this many times but immediately
what comes up for me is okay what what
white people specifically are we talking
about because a white person in the u.s
or norway or south africa or kenya or
australia very different experiences of
so-called whiteness right
um
but i didn't there was no room to even
ask anything like that you had to echo
what everyone else is saying or else you
are the enemy so i saw the division i
really started to see the division in a
way i just hadn't before and i was
buying into it myself
um and it took about a month for me to
almost
snap out of that
and start to
start to just think to myself what the
[ __ ] am i doing
what am i actually participating in what
what what am i doing this is not me
um
but again
i felt very alone in that because no one
else was having any kind of conversation
like that i think the only person that
would have been
having
any conversation similar to that is
aisha it can be i really can't think of
anyone else that was
openly having any kinds of discussions
like that and in that same year you both
interviewed her actually
um
so i would say
the summit of 2020 really was the nail
in the coffin for me but there were a
lot of things that had been coming up
for a couple of years before then and do
you think your sobriety played a massive
part in this because as someone who
doesn't drink i gave up alcohol in 2011.
right and the part of
giving something up is a realization
that you can't live with it anymore yeah
and you can't deceive yourself any
longer
and once you take you start that process
of being honest with yourself and
practicing sort of sort of a form of
radical honesty where you see your life
for what it is
once you start looking at the world
through that lens
you can't stop doing it oh absolutely
and i'm so
gosh i'm so [ __ ] glad that you just
said that because
i always
come back to my sobriety i think with
sobriety that journey it gave me a very
useful framework that can be applied to
so many things
and radical honesty is one of those
things and again it's it's not a
romantic process because i think to say
that time it can sound like it's this
kind of fluffy self-help no it means
that
you have to be in integrity even when
you don't [ __ ] want to
and me writing that letter why i'm
leaving the cult of workness me saying
that i'm not going to dehumanize white
people i'm not going to use the exact
same framework that was used many years
ago in segregation onto another race in
the name of justice i'm not going to do
that
um me rejecting the narrative that i'm a
victim by default because of my skin
color but it's kind of rebranded in this
empowering way which is it's really
weird isn't it it's all i i always call
it um
it's just rebranded tactics all of it if
you really just look at it it's just
rebranded as something new but it's the
exact same thing me rejecting all of
that there was nothing for me to gain
nothing for me to gain at all but
because i'm so committed to being in
integrity no matter what that letter was
gonna [ __ ] happen and it took it took
about two years for me to actually get
it out
but i knew that i had to and yeah i i do
think my sobriety really fueled that
process and you've come a long way
because you mentioned
having watched our interview with asia i
can be at the peak of the of the racial
tensions and i think that's the best way
to describe it um you didn't like it no
no you didn't like us i didn't
you know what's hilarious i feel like
i'm doing the rounds speaking to people
that i didn't like and being like i i
love you now
please take me um
and i'll tell you why i didn't um kk
it's because
i knew that my story was gonna have to
change
i knew that my story was gonna have to
change i knew
that i was going to have to
really sit with the cognitive dissonance
that i felt and the discomfort because
the information that i was taking in it
made sense everything that you
and aisha were talking about it made
sense objectively right you weren't
speaking about your own emotions and
your own feelings things that i think
are useful by the way i'm not i'm not of
the thinking that they're useless but i
think there is a time and a place with
certain conversations what you were
saying made logistical sense
um
but
it didn't align with the way that i felt
because i felt so angry i had been told
that i need to feel angry on the behalf
of all of the people that share my
identity and i was okay with that for
for a time until i was told all of these
other things that i also need to do that
i didn't sit well with me um so even
though i didn't
like
what i was hearing
from all of you speaking about you know
statistics and just speaking about some
of the contradictions et cetera
i start with it i start with it i didn't
reject it straight away
for whatever reason i kept coming back
to the conversations that you had and
looking at what else you've you've been
talking about and i do
remember feeling so jarred by
just how audacious you both are which i
think is such a beautiful thing but just
how bold you are and how unapologetic
you were
and it was very refreshing because i
guess i had been in so many echo
chambers where you have to apologize
for your existence and you have to um
you know preface everything with as a
cis white this as a and you both just
refused to buy into that and that was
the process that i was in saying no
i'm not doing that
um so it was very jarring but also
it was very compelling which is why i
kept coming which is why look where i am
so what pissed you off the most about
the conversations that we were having
i'm serious but that's the interesting
thing is like what is it that really
like oh the truth
the hearing the truth
because again
and i didn't realize that subconsciously
i was finding myself in echo chambers
where the truth wasn't welcome or at
least a certain truth is welcome and
there are unspoken rules we all know
that this is what you speak about this
is what you don't speak about you don't
point out contradictions especially if
you're pointing out contradictions to do
with a certain
race or a certain community or a certain
whatever because there's an unspoken
hierarchy which doesn't [ __ ] exist in
the real world
um so i think it was
hearing truths that i'm not really used
to hearing or at least don't want to
hear i think it's unconvenient right so
i think that's what sort of pissed me
off the most if you will but i don't
think it really really did
um
as i said i think i i just had to change
my story and a part of me didn't want to
because it's much easier to keep
yourself safe in groups where everyone
says the same thing no one disagrees
with you
um
but at the same time there's a hyper
vigilance because you have things you
really want to say but you have to keep
them to yourself you do don't you we do
live in a society which is hyper
vigilant and obviously social media
plays a part yes yes how did you feel
that impact your life
you know what i would say the hype of
vigilance piece didn't really impact me
specifically but i could see it with
other people
i could see that
behind closed doors because i have
always been a very very open person and
with the things that i've been speaking
about in terms of self-sabotage for the
past five years
naturally i have to be open
and i think as someone that has
experienced just so much
[ __ ] with sobriety and blacking out
and just doing things you would never
normally do
um
there's a level of transparency that
comes with having to tell that story
anyway
so
i think because of that a lot of people
trusted me which meant behind the scenes
i would get to see what people really
think
i will get to see that you have this
thing that you want to say but you're so
afraid
of even just asking the question not
stating an opinion asking a question
um
and when i would ask people why even
some of my own clients they would tell
me that you know they have some of their
followers messaging them asking them why
are you following this person
i expected more from you i'm
disappointed that you are
following an individual on social media
so the hyper vigilance piece i saw it
more so from the outside looking in not
experiencing it first hand um but i
wanted to know as well if you if you
both have experienced that to some
degree when you feel like you're being
watched oh yeah
i'll tell you a story i was uh i was i
remember
a friend
called me one day and he goes uh francis
and this i was in the comedy industry
which is ultra work blah blah blah we
know that we know all that
i didn't know that by the way didn't
have the comment no
i think i first heard it from both of
you and joe rogan speaking about it a
little bit but i really didn't know yeah
oh it completely is it completely is all
the liberal arts whether it's theater
whether it's right tv they've all gone
to that side and i remember he called me
up and he goes to me
i've been looking at a lot of your
tweets and you're sounding like a
conservative
and you know you might want to have a
look at that
and i remember i was in a bad mood i
think i had an argument with my
girlfriend and i said the words i don't
give a [ __ ] anymore because i just
was it wrong that you have certain
conservative opinions i have opinions
that are liberal i have opinions that
are conservative i don't identify with
other side because to me that's
tribalism and then you're not being
authentic anymore what you're doing is
being part of a tribe and once you do
that you lose your sense of who you are
your sense of self right
but to me
you get that i just found that shocking
that someone would look through my
tweets it's got enough time in the day
number one
to look through the tweets and going oh
you know you said this you did you did
this and when i had a bus stop
with the same person you remember he
called me and he goes to me you're gonna
lose a lot of your liberal friends
and he was right to be fair to him he
was right it's all right you've got me
it's me africa and anton that is your
social security yeah that's all you need
and the same we were telling you the
story before we started about a friend
of ours who's he's not really you know
he he's just a comedian who happens to
have
all sorts of different opinions and he
got another comedian who said to him the
optics of your tweets lately are right
wing or whatever the phrase was the
industry that we come from unfortunately
it's a very small circle and it's
everybody's watching everybody all the
time right to the point where when i was
sort of in the place that you described
where you came across people who were
doing stuff online that you thought well
i'm learning something
i remember the exact moment for me when
it hit me i watched larry elder
who we've since had on the show on dave
rubin and he did exactly what you were
saying you saw with us and aisha where
he just went fact fact facts stats stats
that's that would like like only larry
can do and i was like oh and then i was
like [ __ ] i now have to believe this
because i can see that it's true
but i know the price for that that's it
so i didn't like
dave rubin's like facebook page for two
years and i don't watch much of dave's
channel because we're doing this now and
you know he's gone in his own direction
we've gone in our own direction whatever
but at the time what he was doing was
groundbreaking and i remember watching
it and being terrified
i wouldn't even subscribe to his channel
on youtube
and there's people who do that with
trigonometry there's people like um
i was chatting to zubi about this the
other day and he he reckons his twitter
following is twice what it is and he's
probably right because there's lots of
people who are afraid to follow the
wrong person yes right yes and i think
the vast majority of people who know
they have something to lose who know
that they're going to be punished at
work who are going to be fired their
opportunities are going to be curtailed
and it's you know it's of course it's
the creative arts but it's also it's
publishing it's it's the media it's
politics to a large extent you know are
you following the wrong person are you
associating with wrong people we've gone
into we went into this thing and i don't
maybe tell me what you think about it
but there was a point where we just went
into this sort of
crazy game that i call six degrees of
white supremacy which is you talked to
us and we talked to this person and he
once stood next to that person he was
walking a dog
and then suddenly you are that person's
six degrees of separation away you are
the white supremacist because you once
talked to the
you know what i mean
that's i think the world we live in and
with what you talk about with
self-censorship that seems to me to be
really the key piece here oh absolutely
absolutely and you know what i always
think of it it's the exact
thing that you just outlined
i think of it as cancellation by
proximity
that's that's the sort of world that
we're in right now and
i also received messages from people
saying
africa i would love to share your
instagram live or your podcast episode
or your post
but i know that if i do i'm going to be
yeah i i'm gonna get it from the mob
online and if you ask yourself i mean go
go onto my social media what the hell am
i even saying i'm advocating for hello
people can we
remember that there's a [ __ ] middle
ground
that's it that's it right yeah just
advocating for nuanced conversations can
we understand the context before we buy
into
a three-minute clip those are the
conversations that i'm having that we
don't have to pick between pro or anti
white or black with us or against us so
many of us and i would argue that the
majority are in that middle ground we're
in the gray area
um but it feels like to even say that
puts you in a certain position
and to me that's [ __ ] crazy
and that is the nature of
self-censorship when it comes to the
point of
it doesn't even take an external mob
to tell you that you can't say that it's
the mob in your mind and that is the
most dangerous thing
where you start to
filter every single thought every single
action every single idea through what
the mob will accept that's frightening
it's terrifying it's it's terrifying i
remember my girlfriend went to a comedy
night
and uh she came back and she's really
into you know more controversial
comedians like stan hope doug stanhope
people like this and i said well what
was it like did you enjoy it my love and
she went
i just found it really boring
because no one was saying anything
interesting no one was actually pushing
the boundaries and i said but
you can't blame them because that's the
system that's the industry if you do
push boundaries if you do for instance
go and do a joke about blm where you
take the piss out at blm you ain't
playing that gig again
it's really nice i mean it would be a
[ __ ] great last gig
he'd go out with a bank
but but you're right and that's in many
ways i think why we started trigonometry
because
that mob in your head that you're
talking about
every comedian in this country who is
not already a multi-millionaire super
successful and even many of them
we've all got that mob in our mind now
everybody everybody i remember i told
the story before i think once there was
a comedian when i used to do comedy we
did a gig together top secret best club
in london in my opinion
and i always used to talk about
political and cultural stuff as a
comedian that's what that's who i am
that's what interested me and i came off
stage and he went oh man why i love the
fact that you do this
i'd love to do that and i was like well
that's great you know like let's do some
writing or whatever and he was like oh
no no i couldn't do that
and i was like why anyone well as a
straight white man
you know what i call that i call it the
script yeah i call it the script because
when i started to pull myself out of all
of that to make sense of some of the
things that were happening i just had to
sort of just
label certain things in a certain way so
i can remind myself not to get sucked in
and that i i always refer to it as the
script because
it's like you're given this role that
you have to play and you don't get to
decide whether you play it or not your
identity markers pick out the role for
you
and when i started to see how many
people especially women for for some
reason
and i'm really looking into this
actually slight tangent but i'm i'm
trying to do a lot of research to see
why
it seems as if it's mainly women that
buy into this culture i find i find that
piece very interesting theories for you
that are not going to go down well with
people
i find it very interesting and it made
me think of something jordan peterson
said a while ago and i've seen some
research on this as well that with women
mainly
kind of tend to go for reputational
damage instead of physical and that
maybe plays a part into why we see women
mainly kind of spearheading a lot of
what we see because i've been looking
into this for the past year i think
there is sort of a gender aspect to it
massively massively right um so if
anyone's listening and they have some
kind of uh thoughts around that useful
thoughts around that that would be
good i mean speaking of jordan p you're
looking very
you looked a bit scared for a second
there about what i mean no it was a face
of wonder yeah
well i i give you a couple of pieces
that may be
maybe irrelevant here number one as we
know from the psychological research
women are more prone to negative emotion
and emotion in general yeah just
fact yeah statistically speaking and if
you think about this ideology
and the cognitive dissonance that we all
experience that you were describing
earlier when we were sort of confronted
by facts versus our own feeling
if feelings are higher priority for you
as an individual because of
your hormones and whatever
that will be more difficult to overcome
with facts right or with statistics or
whatever because your feelings take a
higher priority
negative feelings and and and also women
are more empathetic and compassionate so
if you if you weaponize empathy as i've
talked about in the past right
weaponizing empathy you're saying look i
have empathy for people who are
suffering right we all do now if i come
along and go well look these people have
been oppressed for millions of years and
whatever
that draws people in
and it's weaponizing the empathy against
them because they then can't ask
questions
you have to accept the narrative right
you can't go so when you say you've been
oppressed for a million years well
actually human beings haven't existed
that long like yeah
so that's part of it uh and the other
thing i think about it about as well
women that tend to be more communitarian
they care more about fostering yes
community if you think about the
stereotypical grand narrative mum and
dad
right
in a healthy way
the mom is the one that keeps everybody
getting along and that that is maybe the
one that pushes you and that sort of
thing you know what i mean these are all
generalized stereotypes they don't apply
to every human being but i think those
are some of the pieces why this issue is
gendered in that way
you know emotion uh being more
vulnerable susceptible to negative
emotion and the desire for community and
empathy i think those are the places and
those are wonderful human instincts that
women bring to the conversation but if
you weaponize them against people
and also women get punished more they
get punished more for speaking out
that's the other thing it's more scary
because you you are perceived as more
vulnerable women get way more hate
online for doing the same things that i
do for example
so the punishment is also greater and
therefore it's scarier for women that's
why you know gender critical feminists
for example i have a lot of admiration
for them because it's really really
dangerous
yeah as do i because behind again and
this comes back to
the self-censorship piece
this is really preventing us from having
some really [ __ ] important
conversations because to truly be able
to and i speak to a lot of my trans
friends have you spoken to buck angel
yes yes we have oh isn't bug brilliant
yeah buck's great oh my goodness i'm so
grateful that someone like him exists
but when i speak to people like
buck or just engage with his work or
some of my other trans friends
you realize that the current
conversations that are spreading like
wildfire are really doing a disservice
to the people that really need the help
so when you have
certain trans activists taking on the
role of speaking for everyone else and
taking people 10 20 30 years back
and we can't even ask questions and have
a discussion because people are so
afraid
it's doing nothing it's doing absolutely
nothing and something i wonder what you
think about this but i think
one of the things with
doing self-censorship i think we all
need to be willing to risk something
i think
we are in such extremes of binary
thinking where we think but if i speak
i'm going to lose my income my job my
clients my kids except we go to the
extremes i always say to people
including my clients
yes that that is a possibility but is
that the only truth
right and i think people have an idea
that
to undo self-censorship you need to
speak publicly no
it's about your very intimate
relationships that have been heavily
politicized
it can be a very silent and slow process
between one person
it's you
deciding that the mob in your mind
should not exist to begin with because
even when we say language like oh you
can't say this anymore no who the [ __ ]
gets to decide that you can
and maybe you need to be willing to risk
something
and i think comfort is the bare minimum
that people can risk i think people
think that any kind of discomfort
shouldn't be there to begin with that
means that i should shut up no i i think
you need to be willing to risk something
i think that's the only way through this
um
because accepting that this is just how
it is
and having a few people maybe people
like us
speaking on behalf of others there's
only so much that we can do and i think
it's easy for people to
watch conversations like this and to
maybe
stop there i do think some people start
to see how can i integrate this into the
real world maybe i say hey listen to
this podcast and start to undo that
process
but i think we need to be willing to go
a step further and actually integrate
these things into the real world
i think
lack of authenticity kills people i
genuinely do i think it's an emotional
dry rot you get used to lying you get
used to saying lies and then you tell
lies to yourself and then as a result
you become deeply unhappy deeply
frustrated deeply angry because you know
on some fundamental level that you're
wasting your time and time is all that
you have and if you're doing that
perpetually you realize that you're
wasting your life
and that's when you become angry and
then you have that anger
and then if you don't express that anger
because you're not being honest you then
turn that anger in on you which is what
it's depression and that's why people
sink i think the best thing that we can
all do is just go look
this is what i think and what i feel
yeah
and i just think people are terrified to
do that and they live their life in fear
and it's tragic because
at the most basic fundamental level it's
a waste of a life now look not everybody
not everybody needs i think to to be
going out there and doing stuff in the
public eye or whatever but far from it
but
the world's a staging we're merely
actors and everybody's got a role to
play there are some people for whom the
way to integrate like us for me
integrating that dishonesty that i was
living with resulted in this for france
it's the same for you your life but for
other people it just means
there are people who watch our show we
get people sending us money as you know
watching on the raw show going oh guys
you are some of the best commentators on
youtube please don't read my name out
right
and i respect that i understand where
that's coming from and for some people
that may be the extent of their honesty
is they send money to a channel that's
doing something that they think is
valuable and that they want to see more
of but in their own life they're having
to you know contain that to certain
contexts maybe yes i don't think it's a
healthy environment necessarily but for
some people that's you know they've got
kids to feed and there's other
responsibilities that come into play
so i i'm also aware that asking
everyone yeah we don't i like when i
think about this the way i think about
it is
would the world be a better place if
everybody in the world was constantly
kissing
i don't think no thank you she went
straight away no no
no
[Music]
i think the world would be amazing if if
it was just filled with you no i don't
think it would be i think
in every society you need a creative
destructive element yeah an element of
people who are willing to point at all
the hypocrisies and the flaws and the
whatever but if everybody was doing that
it wouldn't be a healthy society so i
think everybody's got a role to play
yeah and it's not so much about looking
at a screen and going oh i'm going to do
that i'm going to replicate that in my
life i think it's about going what is
the authentic expression yeah of who i
am and what i feel about the world and
my views and how do i and i frankly have
a lot more respect for people who
i don't know build a church or or feed
hungry kids or whatever than people who
do a youtube show you know people who go
out into the real world and do stuff to
me or you know people who who create a
charity that brings people of different
races together and helps them see their
common humanity to me that's infinitely
more valuable than what we do so there's
a there's a thing for everybody i agree
i agree which is why i always emphasize
that if you are someone that is
experiencing just debilitating levels of
self-censorship or even not if you're
starting to think
huh i am finding that if i'm with this
group of people
i end up agreeing with things that i
don't actually really think
i think that is the opportunity to take
the risk that i'm speaking about because
when i say the word risk i don't want
people to go to the extremes again
thinking they have to lose it all no
you have little moments every single day
where you can just behave in a slightly
different way
and just experience that discomfort and
like i said it's a very slow silent
unsexy process most of the time you
don't have to shout about it online i
don't think most things should be online
to to be honest i think it's a very
personal thing and if you do
end up at a point where
you feel like actually i do have
something useful to contribute to a
conversation that's currently happening
you've already done it in your personal
life
you know um and i think that's far more
sustainable even
than trying to
find a strategy to be able to say
something controversial and then put it
online i actually don't think that's
useful because you haven't taken
yourself through a crucial process of
saying actually how do i think how do i
feel about this and testing it out with
a friend because i think it's worrying
and i get thousands of messages like
that it's like what i'm about to tell
you each day
people that
have started to
avoid their family members because they
feel
a different way to maybe what the rest
of them feel because they have different
opinions about the vaccine about
mandates about etc about
and i think to myself but it's your
family it's it's the people that you
should be able to have those
conversations even when you don't agree
so it's not um
something that just people in the public
eye are experiencing it's just the
average person who's probably not even
on social media that is starting to
experience this tension and this
division
and to me i that's the area that i like
to focus on the most it's not even the
people that are necessarily uh have
thousands of followers or an audience
it's the everyday person that is
starting to feel stifled that's what i
care about
because we politicize everything that's
the problem everything is politicized
and a year ago it wasn't like this
over a year ago five years it really
wasn't like it really my goodness
and you think everything now even
whether you're going to take a vaccine
there's reasons to take the vaccine
there's reason it's not to take the
vaccine i believe in bodily autonomy i
believe that you should read up about it
and decide whether you think it's
appropriate answer
cancer he believes in bodily autonomy
yeah and and with with that i think it's
um
because it's exactly where we are right
now
what i also find so sinister is for
example the people that
have experienced let's say an adverse
reaction
and they share their story not not
telling anyone what they should do they
share their story and then they get
called an anti-vaxxer they get attacked
hmm are we is that really where we are
so someone has made a decision maybe
because they think it's for the best
they also want to keep other people safe
etc whatever their reasons are
and they say hey actually i did make
this decision and then this happened is
this happening to anyone else can we
have a conversation you can't
even go there and to me that's a big
[ __ ] problem and and just things like
that are part of why i i won't shut up
about any of this think about what
you're talking about there and i've
never really
thought about it in this way but as you
were speaking i realized this think
about what's happened to the idea of the
truth in that situation
the truth has been made a slave to
convenience god it's been made a slave
to achieving some kind of political
outcome and so
we we don't want to hear your story
about how you had a particular reaction
to a particular medical procedure
because we have an agenda
and your story is not only not important
we're going to suppress it we're going
to shut it down
because we need to achieve our objective
and in order to achieve our objective
we're going to tell you to shut up and
keep your experience to yourself right
that's what's happening there yeah and
it's
so interesting you say that because
i always say similar things about my
work my work resonates with so many
people at this point in time my open
letter has been read by nearly five
million people wow i mean it's not as
short as four thousand [ __ ] words
i couldn't finish it
not short it's not sure right i was
joking it was great thank you
and
i've i've received you might have heard
me say this on on different podcasts
maybe not but i've received
i haven't received any pushback i
haven't received any pushback and the
amount of people
specifically black people brown people
that have i am laughing at brown people
because i always hear the brown bird um
they're some of my favorite jokes
honestly um
she's talking about our raw show which
is completely outrageous just me and
francis talking [ __ ] we do it three
times a week and inexplicably africa
watches it oh i love it please watch it
please watch it um the amount of people
that have told me
just thank you for speaking about this
and
that message that it's convenient it's
inconvenient for so many people
especially so-called activists
and i'm not against activists of course
it would be ridiculous for me to be
against activism i think activism is so
important and it's so needed there's so
many wonderful activists that i know
personally that are on the ground
doing the very unsexy work of making a
difference they don't have big platforms
they don't want to be famous but a lot
of people want the fame
um but my message is inconvenient for
them because a black woman
coming forward
and saying no actually there's a very
one-sided narrative about race and i'm
i'm not buying it i'm not into it and
also this black woman is not affiliated
with the alt-right you know because
that's the angle that you always hear
when people dismiss people like candice
owens
um they will just dismiss her because
she's on the right but i'm i'm not on
any kind of side
if i was to be pushed to say where do
you lean you could say that i'm more
left-leaning but there are many things
that i agree with with people that are
more conservative and people that are
not even politically affiliated anything
um
but again my message is very
inconvenient for people that want to
just sell a very singular idea of the
so-called black experience which anyway
so
we'll talk about that another time so
yeah can we talk about it now yeah sure
what is your message on the race issue
um
that's a broad question well you were
saying that it's inconvenient for some
people to hear you say what you say so
what is what is it that you think that
is inconvenient to right right
to me first of all i think the
way that race has been spoken about
right now is through a very americanized
lens i don't know if you you both have
thought this as well
to me it doesn't really especially
as someone that was born in zimbabwe
came here to the uk when i was nine
years old um
and culturally my life experience is
just very different from let's say
someone who has been born and raised in
the us or someone born and raised in the
uk so i see race in a very different way
i didn't grow up
thinking or being told
that because of the color of my skin by
default i'm somewhat oppressed and i
need to look at anyone who is white as
my oppressor or my victimizer and i am
the victim i it's just not the way that
i was raised culturally it just isn't
so i feel as though in the present day
i'm being forced to step into
a racial conversation that doesn't
align with my actual so-called lived
experience
right and i have a lot of questions
about it um and i think that's the most
inconvenient part because you're not
allowed to say hey but i was born and
raised in zimbabwe and my experience of
my
race is very different um and i actually
don't see myself as oppressed it's not a
some people
and i've had this a few times
will get angry that i don't see myself
as oppressed they will see it as if i'm
denying that's the angle that people go
to oh so you didn't know i can accept
the reality of what's happened in
history
and
also acknowledge that i'm not oppressed
because i think it's a
slap in the [ __ ] face to so many
people in my country who are actually
truly oppressed by the government and
the system that we live under
um
and to be able to sit in the western
world
i'm probably more privileged than most
people
to say that i'm oppressed it just
doesn't i i'm not i'm not doing that um
and i think that's what causes a lot of
friction with activists that have a very
specific americanized message about race
africa
do you think and i think we all have
this
is that there is something i think of we
all have western privilege in this
country particularly people who've been
born and brought up in this country they
look around they only see the flaws they
only see the things wrong with it they
they
magnify in they focus in
on the flaws with this country the
problems with it and they don't see
actually how lucky they are right you
know you grew up in zimbabwe
my mother's venezuelan i went back i saw
what happens when a society unravels i
saw what happens when you quote unquote
um abolish capitalism
and then you see people in this country
wanting to implement those things
implement those ideas put these
narratives and you know
having seen the other side of life that
actually how fortunate we are to be in
this place right yeah and and i think
that's what it is i have something to
compare it to
and i have immense gratitude for
the opportunity that i have and i always
think of
an area of so-called privilege that
people don't speak about which is
possible privilege the zimbabwe
impossible i
i should have not but i shouldn't have i
do have one
but i mean it's it's not the same as
having a british passport
it's it's not the same
and the
just something that's so seemingly
small
that it changes my life in in a way that
most people can never imagine in my
country so to sit here and to say i'm
oppressed and the the most interesting
thing is that some people
through genuine curiosity i will say
okay so can you tell me how
how exactly are you oppressed you know
when people are shouting online and
they're saying oh oppressed
no one can ever tell me
what actually makes you oppressed is it
because you see your
skin color
as a burden
because that's what
so many activists fought for us to not
believe and to think and you're
willingly taking that on a lot of people
again the script that i was speaking
about earlier
a lot of people will be chanting certain
things and when you simply ask a
question okay so tell me
exactly how the whole thing [ __ ]
crumbles because
they don't even know why they're
committing to this idea
um
yeah so i do find that very interesting
i do and quite disturbing
yeah it is i i think the conversation
about oppression is probably even more
nuanced than that because i think if you
look at certainly the history of
immigration into this country the people
who came here from the caribbean in the
50s and 60s were treated very badly yes
and for for some of them the residue of
that and the legacy of that runs to this
day through the family history
and through some of the you know we know
friends comedians uh who at the time of
blm last year were saying well look i'm
not into all of this victimhood stuff
but i as a young black man was first
like stopped by the police when i was
12. yeah and then it happened three
times every year for the rest of my life
so there was
that experience whether it's you know
there are some underlying reasons that
we don't need to get into now that may
explain some of that yes but the
subjective experience of that person is
nonetheless one of
the you know uncomfortable experiences
which are to some extent
caused by their skin color yes right
but at the same time what what triggered
me into not buying into it is when
when it became
these
broad generalizations like you were
talking about all white people list well
actually no people would say that i'm
white my family never benefited from
slavery didn't live in this country most
of my family 50 60 70 80 150 years ago
long after the transatlantic slave trade
ended were slaves right white slaves
jewish slaves taken to germany or slave
laborers or slaves in the soviet gulags
like it's not as simple as white bad
black good it's just not no right and
and we can have a conversation about why
certain groups of uh particularly
caribbean people in this country and in
north america do have a different
experience of life and we should have
that conversation and there are some
problems there that need addressing but
we don't need to demonize people
black or white or brown or whatever the
skin color as a race and this thing
about whiteness
that is literally what you said which is
it's just taking racism and flipping it
in reverse that's all it is yeah that's
all it is yeah but i do
with all of that being said i do
people always ask me so are you hopeful
or do you think everything has just gone
to [ __ ] and we're [ __ ]
um
i am hopeful because the fact that a
year ago
i even though i thought of myself as a
very confident outspoken person i'm in
integrity i've led myself here through
my sobriety journey i don't think i
would have sat here speaking to both of
you i think i would have
if we're just isolating that moment in
time
i
would have sort of just kept this to
myself that this is what i'm engaging in
in terms of just conversation
the fact that we can even have this
conversation and it's not the only one
happening i'm sure you've seen that more
people are starting to feel able to say
hey
something really [ __ ] weird is
happening we need to talk about it or
you know to start to
create comedy sketches that address some
of the things that are happening and you
start to see that things are shifting
you know maybe not as as fast as some
people would like it but i think it's
something is happening that is changing
shifting the tide a little bit um so
that allows me to remain a little bit
hopeful through all of it yeah do you do
you both feel
i
um
i
there are times where i feel hopeful
yeah and then i go on twitter do you
know what i mean and i but but i'm not
on twitter so maybe
so maybe there is because we're starting
to have these conversations the the tone
is less heated we do seem to have cooled
down when it comes to the whole
discussion on race so perhaps we are
the thing that i always find very
worrying and very sad
is how
you see black people who come out and
say look i disagree with this i disagree
with that i'm not on board with a lot of
what blm do i'm not a lot on board of a
lot of what b m say these are my reasons
and then i see
other black people
then use racial epithets against them
and then say the most horrendous things
yeah and that's just normal and i'm
thinking to myself and then i see white
people doing it
like like a friend zooby who comes out
and you know he was very critical of the
blm movement
and then i saw white people saying
racist things to him and everyone was
like oh yeah that's fine
right so so it's almost as if if someone
is labeled a [ __ ] or an uncle tom
that means
they can be treated as if they are an
actual so-called white supremacist so it
doesn't it doesn't matter
again yes so the maximum revoked so the
dehumanization
is almost
just a default of that because they've
been
yeah yeah but i am slightly optimistic
at least on on the wokeness front uh
there's some other things going on right
now that we don't probably don't have
time to get into that make me a lot more
pessimistic but on the stuff we're
talking about here
i do think
the pendulum
has slowed i don't think it's swinging
back at all but i think it's slowing
it's slowing down and slowing down on
the race issue
it's slowing down i think very
noticeably actually
on
you've got to be very careful with words
in in this area but
to me there's a lot of portions of the
feminist movement which i see is very
legitimate and very well intentioned and
rightly existing right and actually
talking about important things and not
just the gender critical this stuff
about domestic violence and all of that
which is really important and it's
unaddressed yeah but there was also a
portion
a few years ago of the feminist movement
which was just about man-hating it just
was
that seems to have died down um
that's encouraging to me and the general
wokeness and social justice thing again
i do feel that it's slowing down and
more sensible people are being you know
a bit more measured about speaking out
against it but a lot of people are now
criticizing it it seems to me like when
barack obama is saying maybe you
shouldn't be quite like we kind of you
know you know what i mean like
he people people might listen to that i
would hope you know um so i think on
that issue actually i'm with you and not
with francis for a change
i've been less infected by his pessimism
in that area i do think we're making
progress i do yeah i do i think the fact
that you're here is progress yeah me too
i think that is progress me too
it's fascinating it's it's a very it's a
very interesting moment
you know we haven't talked about
zimbabwe much
do you think
that
you have an outsider's perspective and
that's what colors your ability to look
at this in a different way
absolutely i do i really do and i'm i'm
so grateful for that actually
because i think it
introduces again another angle that is
important in this conversation because
even though
you hear
you know activists social justice people
chanting black people not a monolith etc
etc
they still
treat you like you are one they still
treat you like you are on because if you
are let's say conservative and from the
right they'll say but you're black
okay
right so so many of those contradictions
do show up and i think
just me being able to offer that
perspective as an immigrant in the uk
um
that doesn't view things in this very
singular way i think that's an important
perspective and i think my me being
zimbabwean is a big part of that yeah
yeah
and do you mind if i'm making some would
i be right and assuming that you come
from like a middle-class family in
zimbabwe is that fair to say or no
just it's just a curiosity working-class
family really working-class fashion in
zimbabwe but the thing is with
most african in most african countries
education is valued it's really really
violent yeah yeah
um you're like the jews
exactly we we are like the jews and
that'll be the title of the yeah
you know there's a lot of black jews
especially
yeah
so education is really valued so you
will have families that are very much
working class that will pour everything
they have
to make sure that their children
actually get an education which is why i
think also with you and i didn't go to
private school or anything like that i
didn't even go to university um but my
family did make sure that we did
especially coming to the uk in 2001
where zimbabwe was on such a decline and
my mom was a geologist in zimbabwe but
when she came here to the uk none of
that was useful
none of she couldn't do anything with
that you can't use
any of your degrees in the same way she
had to start from zero
um she had to do nursing she was staying
in student halls she had four kids i
have two older sisters one younger
brother so i don't come from
a privileged background in the sense
that people might assume
um but my family and my mom in
particular has worked so [ __ ] hard
um to get herself and pour everything
into us to get ourselves to where we are
right now which is why again a lot of
the um
language and a lot of the messaging that
is being put out at the moment i i
completely reject it because it
shrinks the real and very individual
experiences of people globally
um
so yeah again i do think my upbringing
in zimbabwe from
a working-class family um that wasn't in
poverty or anything like that but just
regular people
working in a zimbabwe that was thriving
and just took a nosedive and having to
start again and having the privilege of
coming to the uk at a time where it was
much easier to come into the uk now if
you're coming from zimbabwe into the uk
it's very very difficult to even get
into the country
um so yeah there are so many threads to
to not only my story but many people's
story and i think
again repeating myself here but the
current narrative about race and
identity and experiences it just shrinks
all of that
and makes everyone into just blobs you
know
um
so yeah
it's also about aspiration isn't it
because if you you can't
see yourself as a victim and at the same
time aspire right to be something to you
know to achieve something or to run a
business the two things are mutually
incompatible because if you think that
the world's against you are never going
to achieve anything then you're never
going to aspire
and that's part of my problem with this
is that it says to people oh
you're a victim
you know the system is against you yeah
you're never going to you're never going
to be able to achieve because you're of
this you know you're in this group and
you're oppressed and to me that just
seems so toxic and harmful right it just
keeps people in the exact same cycle so
this is where i
what i call collective sabotage comes in
because
you're just getting in the way of your
supposed goal but then i think to myself
actually for most of these people they
don't have a [ __ ] goal no one talks
about what is the actual goal here no
one ever offers solutions um
and for me that that was especially last
year another moment of awakening just
thinking hold on
why doesn't for example blm the
organization why don't they seem to ever
offer solutions what is that about again
it's just a simple question it's not me
stating anything specific
just a question and i think just
introducing those questions to yourself
can kind of just crack the veneer a
little bit it's a very good point and
you know your point about collective
self-sabotage i really want to dig into
that because
one of one of the things i've done a lot
in my life is personal development stuff
and i've tried as much we talked with
richard granin a couple of weeks ago
about shadow integration yes about
dealing with the fact that hey you've
got demons and they need and it sounds
like you've been on that journey and
you've kind of got your [ __ ] sorted out
in many ways but there's more there's
always more right and you have to keep
keep working on it but one of the things
that having someone who who looked into
this deeply and looked into the impact
of trauma and the impact of
childhood experience and whatever on the
things that we seek out to look at and
whatever
it was kind of always obvious to me that
and to me it was easiest to see in that
man-hating
bit of feminism right
because i just looked and and you you
know if you've been enough if you've
been around enough people you can start
to see
people's childhoods and and traumas
manifest themselves in the way they
carry themselves the ways they talk the
way they
they carry it themselves
a lot of it was just
i had a bad experience with men
now the world must be a patriarchy so
that my experience isn't just me having
had a bad experience with one person but
rather it's the world yeah and now it
makes sense and at least i'm not the odd
one out here yeah it's all women all
women are victims and all men are evil
right you know and i'm just fortunate
that my wife is really the opposite of
that so it was easier for me to feel
okay with that belief because that's a
scary belief for a man to have in the
modern world you know yeah for a young
man to have in the modern world this
idea that actually you know it's not
what you're being told in many ways um
and i think that collective
self-sabotage is such a big part of this
isn't it it really really is because
it also speaks to
just the rejection of uh personal
responsibility which i know is very
triggering for a lot of people
that was
think it's hilarious
um
but
it's almost we've
just made projecting normal right if i'm
going through this very specific thing
and if i see a post i don't like or a
conversation that is happening that i
don't like and i have a
emotional and physical response to it i
don't have to [ __ ] deal with it i'm
gonna make sure that everyone else
[ __ ] deals with it i'm gonna pour it
out into the world and because we have
channels like social media you don't
even have to
it it incentivizes you to be as reactive
as possible you don't have to sit with
yourself and you can find your own
little community and echo chambers where
you can project your inner happenings
and then you're likely to find people
that are also in the exact same
situation maybe they don't want to take
responsibility for what's really
happening because that's also another
really uncomfortable process
but we've rejected discomfort as an
essential part of growth and i always
say that it's very different from pain
discomfort is essential you will feel it
whether you like it or not but are you
gonna deal with it
and people don't want to deal with it so
they project it outward everyone else is
the problem there's always some kind of
system and i do think there are systems
that we need to question but not
everything needs to be broken down not
everything can be answered by it's the
system it's the patriarchy it's
whiteness there are so many intricacies
to all of that um
so what that happens is that it just
becomes a collective game everyone is
just sort of dancing in this
disillusionment
and
again i'm so fascinated by that and i'm
more interested
in understanding what's really happening
there than just making it a work or
anti-work conversation i think it's much
more useful to think okay we're
we seem to be sabotaging ourselves as a
collective we seem to kind of want the
same thing we just have different ideas
about how to get there we seem to have a
lot of people that are emotionally
unstable
um
right again
right
this is something as well that i'm
researching and speaking to different um
just activists as well
because it's so easy to
get famous
to have a platform someone might put an
idea out into the world i i agree with
you especially seeing it around 2018 in
terms of just people outwardly saying
kill all men hate men etc and then that
goes viral now you have a brand it's
just a young person or a young girl
someone who's disgruntled or they've
experienced something very real
but now they have a brand and now they
have to perform according to that very
singular message that made them who they
are but now they have two hundred
thousand three hundred thousand people
following them
and now it becomes a collective game
right yeah and as i remember especially
at that time
you had people i wouldn't mention who
the particular influencer of this was
but now she's huge she had a very
successful book
people divorcing their partners breaking
up with their boyfriends
because she's telling them to
right but it's someone who's not
qualified and it's highly unethical
that's something that i also like how
unethical all of this is
um
but yeah it's people who are very
emotionally unstable most of the time
they need genuine mental
health support
but then they find these very
um
attractive
messages that tell them that they don't
have to take responsibility it's
everyone else do you think we're
weaponizing guilt a lot of the time oh
for sure guilt and shame and and a lot
of other things but i would say guilt
and shame
especially yeah and and that
because this is what one of my friends
actually said this to me we're talking
about wokeness
and uh
he was an asian guy and he was we were
talking about it and he was just like oh
well it is it's just weaponizing white
gears uh is yeah weaponizing white guilt
was it was it weaponizing or yeah he
used that term right yeah yeah that's
what it is right that's all it is and
you know who speaks about this very well
i don't know if you've spoken to him
already john john mcwhorter
and his book woke racism um
how a new religion betrayed black
america um
i really appreciate that book because
it's not just your typical work or
anti-white conversation he really delves
deep and look at how this is becoming a
religion and i've heard many people
speak speaking about how it's very it's
very much like a religion but the very
simple way in which he breaks that down
i just think it's very interesting for
anyone who's curious even just to see
some of the conversations he's having
just around this i think it allows all
of us to have language to what's
happening
without thinking oh my goodness this
thing is sudden it's come out of nowhere
you start to think actually this might
be a bit more ancient than we think
it's just presenting itself in the
modern world just in a very different
and very unique way well we're just apes
with smartphones yeah really aren't we
and so a lot of this stuff it's
difficult because that's a that's a bit
racist
[Laughter]
i said
i'm going to be the only one hosting
this show
that's all we are and so you know one of
the things that i often think about very
carefully is the moment i see myself
going down one of these
paths where it's like oh if i just go a
bit further i can get a few more
retweets or whatever i instantly slapped
myself in that moment when the moment i
i start to notice that
and it's unfortunate that it happens and
it happens a lot i've seen you know
we've seen people sit in that chair you
know who go who go from
on the similar journey to you but their
end point is way off the deep end
because they
they they get caught in that process
they get
the the
that
that loop of
oh if i just tweet this
you know and it it it it it can't take
people it can take people on a journey
to a bad destination as well yeah oh
that's such a good
point to bring up because another
question i get quite often and i speak
about it quite often is
just to make sure that you're not
leaving one echo chamber just to step
into another one because something i do
see especially with a lot of the
anti-white conversations anti-cancer
culture
it's the exact same thing as before it's
just dressed up differently
and i think that's something to be
really mindful of which is why i'm
find it so refreshing which is why i
love that i sat down with both of you
and we're having this conversation
because it
touches on all the other parts that
maybe people are not seeing because
all they've done is just step out of one
okay chamber into another one it
reinvent the exact same thing
and your ego starts to get um
to really thrive off the attention that
you get from being purposefully
either controversial or saying things
for the sake of external validation etc
which is exactly what we're trying to
right yeah so yeah well we all have to
fight that it is within ourselves but
it's also a deeper thing isn't it in
that we we
we all just want to try
yeah we just want a tribe and the moment
you step out of your tribe you're
terrified
you're on your own you know you people
who you were your support network are no
longer there so you think to yourself oh
there's a new tribe i can
right and then you're right back where
you started just in a different way
the good thing about it for me is i
don't want to be part of any [ __ ]
tribe just get get your tribes away from
me i don't want to be part i don't want
to be part of your work tribe i don't
want to be part of your right wing or
anti-work tribe or whatever it is i'm
interested in the truth yes i'm
interested in an honest discussion and
an honest discussion
will never be right or left-wing because
an honest discussion requires nuance and
nuance is inevitably by including both
sides in our conversation right that's
why we're moving in the direction that
we're moving we never wanted to be an
anti-woke show it's never been our
intention yeah never been on and it's
not interesting to us right you know
we are not in favor of wokeness but
we're not going to bang on about it
endlessly i think
like you said there's a lot of people
now speaking about it and there's more
interesting conversations to be had like
the one we've had today yes
yes i love that and we were saying that
actually before we started recording
that
um
it's not about rejecting the importance
of those times where it was it was
essential to
express the frustration around what we
know as weakness
um
but then you get to move on from that i
think that's what some people don't
remember that you don't have to stay
stuck in that even if that is what maybe
got more attention at the time
and what was current and what people
needed you don't have to stay stuck in
that you can also evolve
which
goes against the very nature of
everything we're being told that people
don't change that who you were ten years
ago five years ago is who you are right
now
i think we get to disprove that by
shifting the way you do approach
conversations and i think you you're
both doing that very very well very well
and it just shows the problems with
labels immediately you put this label on
or you use this label you get given
certain values which you have to ascribe
to
then you were in a tribe and then like i
said
we don't solve anything yeah yeah we
need to step out of the tribe and
actually be honest and it goes back to
integrity and start saying what we think
and what we feel and realizing that
people might disagree with us but if we
allies so closely with a particular
group we're never going to be able to do
that yes yeah
africa we're without noticing it we've
been talking for way longer than we
normally do because as you can tell
we've i think we've all enjoyed it
but uh our time is up we're going to ask
you a couple of questions for our locals
only supporters but before we do we've
got one final question are you
vaccinated
[Laughter]
actual final
question is what's the one thing we're
not talking about as a society that you
think we really shouldn't be
can it be anything anything absolutely i
think we need to revisit how [ __ ]
good the sopranos is i've been watching
it again and it's
it's a really good study on human
behavior
and for me it's a good study on goodness
right how conflicted you can be on is
someone good or are they bad isn't
holding multiple truths about a person
um which is what we really need to be
doing at this moment in time i think
we've got really stuck in
binary thinking good or bad
when actually we can hold multiple
truths about someone and for me i've
been watching i mean i love cinema i
think cinema is a very good way to kind
of just
be able to even answer certain questions
you have around just existing in general
and the sopranos for me is one of those
fantastic well thank you so much for
coming on where can people find your
work online yes so i the only social
media i have is instagram at this moment
in time twister
i don't know how you both do it um i
love it
you can find me africa think about it
like i've got what like 95 000 followers
i can piss off 95 000. you can and the
press of a button gosh isn't that
incredible your resilience must be
actually it is it is i think people that
are on twitter and can be on there and
be okay you need to be a very resilient
person so i do admire that but i'm not
on there yet just instagram it's at
africa brooke with an e at the end and i
have two podcasts as well um my podcast
beyond the self is all about the
individual it's about how to focus on
what you can control but it's not
self-helpy abstract stuff it's really
practical um and i think i think you get
a lot of out of it um and then i have
another podcast called unfiltered with
africa brook where i look at collective
sabotage
and it's about finding middle ground in
a divided world and i think your viewers
especially will really enjoy that i'm
sure they will check it out thank you
guys for watching and listening we'll
see you very soon with another brilliant
interview like this one or a raw show
which even very cool people like africa
watch so make sure you tune in for one
of those there's three of those a week
thursday friday saturday and we'll see
you very soon they always go out at 7pm
uk time and for those of you who like
your trigonometry on the go it's also
available as a podcast take care and see
you soon guys
we hope you've enjoyed this incredible
interview remember to subscribe and hit
the bell button so that you never miss
another fantastic episode and if you
believe that the work we do here at
trigonometry is important support us by
joining our locals community using the
link below